these days it feels like just about
everyone is in love with the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
but even though plenty of big name Oscar
caliber stars have signed on to the MCU
there are some actors who aren't so
enamored with Marvel movies and aren't
afraid to say so here's a look at some
big-name actors who have criticized the
MCU Simon Pegg in 2015
Simon Pegg bit that hand that beats him
by trashing science fiction and comic
book movies saying Society was being
quote infantilized by superhero movies
and that their quote taking our focus
away from real world issues Pegg called
out Avengers age of Ultron specifically
saying that films used to give us
challenging emotional journeys now we're
walking out of the cinema really not
thinking about anything other than the
fact that the Hulk had a fight with a
robot unsurprisingly Pegg also had a
bone to pick with Marvel Studios over
how they treated his pal Edgar Wright
saying that Wright's original ant-man
script was daring fun and hugely
exciting shame we won't see it Jodie
Foster the Avengers and their ilk may
save the world on-screen but according
to Jodie Foster when it comes to the
hearts and minds of audiences they do
the exact opposite Foster told Radio
Times she had no interest in directing
superhero movies and she compared Marvel
and DC's films to literally harming the
planet she said studios making bad
content in order to appeal to the masses
and shareholders is like fracking you
get the best return right now but you
wrecked the earth it's ruining the
viewing habits of the American
population and ultimately the rest of
the world
guardians of the galaxy writer and
director James Gunn responded on Twitter
saying I think Foster looks at film in
an old-fashioned way where spectacle
film can't be thought provoking creating
spectacle films that are innovative
humane and thoughtful is what excites me
about this job George Takei in 2016 when
Tilda Swinton was cast as Steven
Strange's mentor the ancient one in
Marvel's Doctor Strange critics accused
Marvel of whitewashing dr. strange
co-writer see Robert Cargill responded
by claiming that they made the character
Celtic instead of Tibetan in order to
avoid angering Chinese
sensors that didn't sit well with Star
Trek icon George Takei who posted on
Facebook you cast a white actress so you
wouldn't hurt sales in Asia this
backpedaling is nearly as cringe-worthy
as the casting Marvel must think we're
all idiots he went on to point out that
they moved the Ancient Ones headquarters
from Tibet to Nepal anyway which should
have taken care of the issue to begin
with it wouldn't have mattered to the
Chinese government by that point whether
the character was white or Asian there
was already in another country Jessica
Chastain in August 2014 while speaking
to the rap about women having difficulty
finding good roles in Hollywood Jessica
Chastain singled out Scarlett
Johansson's Black Widow as an example of
a powerful female character and said the
fact that Marvel hadn't made a solo
black widow movie made no sense I don't
understand it why is it taking so long
for this to me it's a no brainer you
want to make money put Scarlett
Johansson in a superhero movie there's
some good news though after the success
of 2017 s Wonder Woman Marvel finally
began listening and a Black Widow film
is currently in development
Chloe Bennett you wouldn't think someone
currently working for Marvel would take
potshots at them but agents of shield
star Chloe Bennett did just that in 2016
when she expressed frustration with her
show consistently being ignored by the
movies even though they take place in
the same shared universe she told a
crowd of fans at a comic-book convention
people who make movies from Marvel why
don't you acknowledge what happens on
our show well you guys go ask them that
cuz they don't seem to care I'm kind of
like ready for Steve Rogers to make an
appearance on our show I'd be okay with
that and like where's Romanoff where's
the Avengers Christopher Eccleston Thor
the dark world star Christopher
Eccleston is another one-time Marvel
employee who wasn't quite so happy with
the studio not because they didn't give
his character enough attention but
because they gave him way too much
Eccleston told Graham Norton that in
order to play the evil Malekith
Eccleston had to endure several hours in
makeup every day something he says
Marvel hid from him when he signed on
Marvel were dishonest to me because they
never ever let me know that there'd be
that amount of makeup and he was even
more direct when speaking to the
Guardian about the
Ariane's Thor just a gun in your mouth
so you know don't count on Malekith
coming back to pester Thor anytime soon
Mel Gibson considering Mel Gibson once
said of a critic I want to kill him I
want his intestines on a stick I want to
kill his dog you have to take it
seriously when he starts complaining
about excess violence calling superhero
films violence without conscience in an
interview with The Washington Post he
contrasted his approach to the 2016
drama hacksaw Ridge with Marvel's output
look at any Marvel movie they're more
violent than anything that I've done but
in my movies you give a [ __ ] about the
characters which makes it matter more
that's all I'll say
Jason Momoa even before Jason Momoa made
his debut as Aquaman in the DC extended
universe the star at a fans request
personalized an autographed photo with
marvel at the Indiana Comic Con the
photo and particularly the offending
phrase traveled quickly across the web
feeding fuel to the decades-old Marvel
DC rivalry to his credit amoA wasn't too
pleased about the autograph going viral
explaining a Puerto Rico Comic Con that
it was just a joke that got blown way
out of proportion thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love too